primera cosa que se va con este nerviosa
es el castellano
así que a ver
bueno por mi procedencia y realidad
sociales tienen cantones donde han
nacido siempre me he planteado
he pensado sobre los a la clasificación
de colores asociada a raza o rojo blanco
negro y amarillo una reducción de agua
que para mí era mucho más rico esta es
mi familia con miembros activos
incluidos santiago y la sangre o por lo
menos en mi retina los distintos colores
que forman la populación brasileña y
dentro de ellos nunca me he sentido
diferente pero fuera de mi familia
algunas veces pues para eso
ha creado
me he planteado hacer como un catálogo
de colores pero de colores reales
para eso intenté buscar un médico o agua
que fuese un sistema técnico o un
sistema técnico industrial donde un
color no tuviera más importancia que
otro y por eso elegí las escalas
cantones porque los colores primarios
tenían la misma importancia de los
colores mezclados
las fotos de este inventario cromático
se hacen de una manera muy sencilla y
fácil repetir es fácil de repetir en
fondo blanco
los trazos en fondo blanco siempre con
un cuadradito de 11 x 11 píxeles de la
nariz es el color que aplicó en el fondo
y es el que busca el correspondiente
pantone a la elección de la nariz es
intencional porque es la primera parte
del cuerpo que cambia cuando tomamos el
sol con estamos es fría 2 cuando bebemos
demasiado así que ni una ni uno mismo
tiene un único color como ese chico
el proyecto desde el principio está
planteado como un proyecto online global
con convocatorias públicas
absolutamente todos son bienvenidos en
el proyecto que ha tenido muchísima
empatía con el público y al final mira
son nuestras nuevas identidades no son
las identidades online
ese proyecto que empezó de una manera
familiar y que ha tomado como
proporciones borgeanas porque siempre me
faltan colores y al principio yo lo
planteo como proyecto que viajé por los
cinco continentes
lo más curioso de ese gran proyecto más
curioso de este gran proyecto fue la
cantidad de trabajos que han surgido a
partir de él un proyecto que está en
acabado pero que genera cosas mientras
tanto no una es que límites son que es
un profesor de la universidad de
illinois que usa pues los retratos de
humana y para hablar en sus clases sobre
auto fisiología este es con seymour
'jaume i' que ha decidido en el ámbito
científico hacer todo un análisis
estadístico sobre los colores del
porcentaje que tenía de cada uno que
había pues más de tanto de un tono que
del otro
ese es un trabajo bellísimo de mi jardín
porque lo que le interesa es la variedad
formal de los restos que presenta en el
trabajo yo público las fotos en el
tablero ella los dibuja a papel
y desde los ángeles y tan estamos
completamente conectadas por un trabajo
que está en acabado
ese es el trabajo de anna vasconcelos
una profesora infantil de sao paulo que
después de enseñar el proyecto para sus
alumnos
y les da pimientos para que los mezclen
y después ellos
se dibuja no es un poco crear esta
identidad personal e intransferible y
destruir por completo lo que conocemos
como el lápiz de color carne que no que
ese lápiz de colocarle no
una de las cosas más emotivas y de las
mayores recompensas y ahí es un poco la
vuelta que yo hablaba sobre adopción en
mi familia en las familias son los
medios que es tipos de familias
adoptivas familias de acogida que hablan
como este juego hogareño y cómo
identificar esas imágenes y mira todos
los colores nos iguala eso es una de las
cosas que es la mayor recompensa de este
proyecto
esta familia es preciosa y siempre digo
que con humala yo he aprendido a ser un
mero catalizador yo soy un canal donde
las personas cuentan en parte mi
historia y no dejan de contar las suyas
también porque están ellos que están
contando lo que estoy diciendo humana y
es como una invitación a presionar el
botón compartir que tenemos en nuestro
cerebro igualarnos todos a través de
matrices somos 1.076 y espero que seamos
miles y miles y miles muchísimas gracias